uh drew brees has been running the
offense in new orleans since 2006.
three weeks and one day now what do you
got to count
my math
yes
because sean payton was on with us
and he said he said with no equivocation
now again it may be another john lynch
situation but he said there's no re he
said we expect an announcement within a
week to a week and a half
he said it i know we're three weeks in
one day
removed and there's no announcement
right there's no announcement that drew
brees is retired and he's already
slashed he he did what we suggested that
ben could do if ben really doesn't care
about what he's making all right take
your salary all the way down to the
minimum drew's done that with no quid
pro quo no trade-off it was a it looked
like just a gesture of goodwill to the
saints at a time when they're figuring
out how best to manage the cap charge
arising from the money paid to drew
brees in the past and when i saw that he
dropped his salary with nothing in
return from 25 to 1.075 creating
24.925 million in cap space for the
saints right i i that's it he's done
he's retiring why would you why would
you give up all that money all the way
down to the minimum yeah and get nothing
back unless this is just a precursor to
walking away and leaving the team in the
best pa best possible cap position after
you retire but he still hasn't he still
hasn't and so was it good will or do you
think it was a power play to kind of
push i don't know i don't i don't know i
mean here we are three weeks in one day
removed and shereen williams and i were
debating this a little bit last night on
pftpm she's like well you know he's busy
he's got things going on you want to
pick the right time to have the
retirement press conference and make the
announcement well that's fine but three
weeks and one day ago he told sean
payton was under the impression it was a
week to a week and a half away now maybe
he was wrong maybe there was a
miscommunication maybe circumstances
have changed as to the timing of the
announcement but or the announcement is
made maybe the circumstances have
changed as to whether he is going to
retire yeah i know that's that's what i
think about i i you know as of course
you know we get the text from pete late
last night as far as what what the
rundown is and you start to think about
these type of things
and
you know
one of the things that at least popped
to my mind was just like
i mean was was drew brees you know
a little taken back by the fact that
sean payton made that comment and tried
to put pressure on the situation there
you know as we've seen over the last
year or so
peyton has made many
messages cryptic messages you're right
to go like hey yup you're right he's
pushing buttons to kind of let you know
i feel like he's really kind of trying
to talk to drew in his camp to go like
this is the last year right
right like he's trying to say that
and i don't know where this goes this is
going to be interesting it really is
because yeah it looks like you know with
between what mickey loomis said now now
he gets a million dollar contract the
fan base is like well of course we want
to bring drew brees back for a million
dollars i mean hold on would be great
and all that so the pressure and
everything goes back to the saints now a
little bit and they're stuck here so
i'll be very interested to see
where this goes
but
you know a lot like big ben there's just
you know there's signs you know here
with drew brees a legend awesome i mean
i'd do anything to have drew brees his
career do anything
but i think being realistic too
you know he's not the strength of the
team anymore that that is where i guess
i'd want to say he is not like teams
aren't going into playing the new
orleans saints going oh man we're
playing drew brees this week man we got
to defend every part of the field and
how do we stop him and do all of that no
that's shifted the last two years it's
certainly not that way anymore and i
think we could you know we certainly
could argue his inability to stretch the
field and do things like that are
certainly part of the reason of their
you know underwhelming play-off
performances the last few years so
that's where this this conversation gets
you know very dicey interesting
controversial everything
49 regular season wins over the last
four years and they haven't made it to
the super bowl the only team to win that
many games in a four-year stretch in the
regular season and not get to the super
bowl but i can't help but wonder whether
or not drew brees
witnessed what tom brady did
it's a good team
that the saints swept and it's just
gnawing at him it's driving him crazy
i can't walk away with my last game
having been a loss at home to a guy that
i swept
to a guy that i'd previously been what
five and two against it was some
something scary it was like that you're
right right i can't i that can't be
the last chapter of my career i and he
had a horrible passer rating that day 38
and a half i think was the number that
can't be the last chapter he can't
because
i i think that drew brees is setting
himself up for years of torment
wondering what if what if what if what
if what if and even if it's just a
matter of him coming back saying hey
look sean
i'll share the job we'll taste them let
you know i i'll be i'll be the first and
second down quarterback you pull me on
and off the field whenever you want i
don't care taking the 1.075 million if
he's using that as a precursor to saying
you know what i am going to play that's
a gesture of i'll do whatever you want i
just want to be part of a team that i
still think is in this window to win a
super bowl and wouldn't it be great if
we could find a way to maximize the
assets we have and and get to a super
bowl and win it and he's 41 and brady's
43
and you know we had the graphic up of
the average target down the field it's
not like it's dropped dramatically drew
brees hasn't dramatically changed in
recent years
it was the 2018 season in the postseason
when they had that play drawn up for ted
ginn and he under through it we've known
for a while that brees hasn't had the
ability to get the ball down the field
and maybe secretly the saints have been
wishing and hoping or at least sean
payton wishing and hoping that brees
will move on
but i i i look at it this way
if if there's chicken salad to be made
out of this situation peyton can do it
and if freeze decides he wants to play
what peyton has to ask himself is do i
finally have the talk with him
or do i say fine let's do it right
that's that's the question that peyton's
going to have to resolve if brees really
is having second thoughts about
something that we were led to believe is
inevitable then again maybe it never was
inevitable maybe someone was just trying
to speak it into existence no i i mean
it's it's
you're right sean payton might have to
have that talk with them i i you know
again
even that i mean
i don't i don't know i grew up in an era
too where you got to this point too
there was nothing wrong with going no
you're going to have to win your job in
training camp next year you want to come
back all right well you're going to have
to compete we're going to see taste some
hills you literally grew up you saw with
your dad i know
almost on the browns i know over it i
saw all of it i mean we saw joe montana
get thrown out of the wind the did the
door by the 49ers like see ya great you
won four super bowls two years later get
the hell out of here we're moving on i
mean we've we've seen it everywhere uh
it's just not part of this era but
either way
you know i think what's you know like
you you hit you hit the nail on the head
he's never been like a big time arm or
anything like that there's there's no
doubt it's not been but i do think
within the last
two to three years
it's become
a little alarming because you know three
years ago
he could still you still had a like oh
you know he might throw the deep post or
the go route here you know we can't just
totally disregard it you know we're
getting to the point now where
hey we got to throw it deep we bring
taste some hill in hey we gotta throw it
deep and we need a touchdown bring
jameis winston off the bench to throw
the trick pass
like that's where it's gotten to and
there's too many games where you go
forget the deep passes the 40 and the 45
yarders and all that there's too many
where we came back on mondays during the
year and we went
the 15 and 20 yard passes were barely
getting there and they barely have
enough steam on them to you know get in
a window or do anything like that and to
me that's where it's concerning as
compared and i don't like sitting here
saying this i really don't i don't even
feel comfortable saying saying it about
drew brees because he's so awesome but
that's just that's the way i see it and
you know me i study football i watch
these guys all the time and
um that that's the problem for the
saints and their offense right now
well
this thing was supposed to be automatic
and it's been anything but and until
it's done it's just like
ben roethlisberger to kind of finish
where we started until we get the
announcement
that a new contract has been reached
securing roethlisberger's status for
2021 in pittsburgh
it's possibly going to fall apart
until we get the announcement that drew
brees is retired it's possibly going to
fall apart and he's possibly going to
try to play and the saints possibly are
going to have to tell him
sorry that ship has sailed right and
then drew brees is gonna have to ask
himself a question that he has resolved
many times over
by saying he would never play for a team
other than the saints would he play for
a team other than the saints and i think
this is a far cry from last year with
tom brady and philip rivers because i
think for the same reasons ben
roethlisberger would have a hard time
finding tigers elsewhere at this point
three years ago when drew brees became a
free agent and decided to stay with the
saints and not look around i it would
have been a no-brainer i was saying
vikings should sign him instead of kirk
cousins right i was saying it loudly and
clearly i don't know that that same
sentiment is going to be out there for
other teams given where drew brees
currently is he's 41 years old and that
that that arm strength that window that
range has been shrinking right uh i i i
just i don't see it happening that he
would go anywhere other than new orleans
he is an icon in new orleans which makes
it all the more delicate for the saints
it definitely does he decides he wants
to give it one more goal that's where
that's where i mean i i think you know
that's the difference in that stitch
like you know brady and rivers last year
when teams evaluated them
there was still enough to go
man
they make plays brady's arm's still
strong okay yeah he might have been
reluctant to throw the ball down the
field to some underwhelming cast of
characters at receiver and do all that
but you could see
there was still an arm to make plays and
do that rivers you know two years ago as
last year with the chargers there was
still a number of plays where he went
wow damn that was a good play holy cow
um
even big ben there's a little of that
still to where you go well that's damn
good throw whoa he could big ben's is
more about is his health going to hold
up or his legs going to hold up is he
going to hold up is his elbow going to
hold up
brees is truly about ah i don't know if
there's just enough juice there on film
and that's where i think it's saints or
bust to your point and and yeah i'm
interested to see how sean payton and
the saints approach this whole situation
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports